thank you so much for being here today
happy to be here with you great so I
want to start by having you tell us a
little bit about what experience or
Insight prompted you to start your
company ah
why entrepreneurship
so many problems to solve yeah on the
continent and the content gives you an
opportunity to be a trailblazer
gives an opportunity to be an innovator
Creator to create a path where nothing
exists and then also create a pipeline
for the people I see my entrepreneurship
Journey as a mission to give permission
to other people to dream I see my role
as an enabler of society
Africa has the youngest population in
the world
Nigeria has the largest part of its
population as young people someone's got
to create jobs for these young people
and so when you connect with purpose
which is in solving problems in
innovating and creating something you
have a whole system that needs hands you
know and then you can employ those young
people right you know I like to say that
Nigeria many countries on the continent
it's like a startup
you know there's so many opportunities
so many resources so many potentials you
now need the people to go in and take
those opportunities as resources and
create businesses that will then open up
more opportunities and also to create
the value chain because sometimes you
find out on the continent you know the
resources is there but there's no value
chain right and there's the value chain
that creates the employment
it's the value chain that gives you the
highest profitability you know so these
are things that were you know day
day-to-day embracing on the continent I
mean in different countries from Ghana
to Nigeria Senegal to Egypt and and
we're getting we're getting somewhere
particularly in a new world where you
know social media has made the world a
smaller place you know and made business
quite easier you know to do
um Partnerships and connections you know
easier so if I if I look back will I do
it again I would it's uh 20 years this
year from my entrepreneurial journey and
the business that I founded which I yeah
uh handed over to a CEO last year is 18
this year red for Africa right dating
this year yeah now tell me about the
founding story for that tell me how it
got from an idea in your head to to this
company that's now 18 years old ah is
that it's it's we won't leave here today
you you know but it was it was just
being passionate about you know telling
stories the passion began from me you
know believing that we needed to have
alternate stories to what was being
peddled as our reality uh one for young
people for the longest time young people
were presented as you know lack of
vision not capable have no character
have no competence and I was meeting
young people I thought had competence
capacity cut and I wanted to change that
narrative I also was dealing with a
situation where Nigeria or maybe at the
country in Africa were seen in a certain
way and I wanted to change that
stereotype so it was was two-pronged one
part is how we see ourselves the telling
the stories of a balanced narrative and
the narrative that prompts and gives you
inspiration to wake up we hope to do and
then the other part is telling the world
who we truly are yes there's this part
but there is also this part you know it
began from that since I was about 9
you know and then when I was about I
think 15 you know I started trying to
you know go into the media space
um and I found a partner
um and kind of began a small company and
in 2003 we were I think breaking up the
com no in 2005 where where we
metamorphos into red we had a new
partner he was also passionate about
storytelling what we wanted to do was
simply to use the media to change the
world but as a business we then created
a marketing consultancy
um such that we also then can make money
you know because passion must also be
filled with money you must be able to
pay your bills
um so while we're passionate about
changing the narrative and inspiring
people we're also doing a great job in
selling in you know marketing and that
marketing company eventually evolved
into a political consultancy
um so at some point we were called the
accent of Africa because we then you
know also worked with presidents we run
major campaigns uh uh we we ran the
campaign for president Goodluck Jonathan
in Nigeria we ran the campaign for
president muhammadu buhari of Nigeria
president of Seneca president of Ghana
so in actual fact as I speak to you now
we have three presidents in office that
our company ran their campaigns wow um
as I speak to you now you know so that's
the commercial side of our business yeah
but the real passion side is creating
you know content and platforms that
Empower young people and also employ
them right now speaking of empowering
and also creating content I know you are
really passionate about the state of
women entrepreneurship on the continent
so much so that you wrote a book about
it which I believe you have here right
now but I would love for you
tell me about uh the creation of this
book and how it came about it was simple
it was a simple idea I wanted to write
to my God daughters
it was almost like me writing a letter
to my goddaughters
um I'm aware that I live in a world
where people tell women what they can be
and cannot be especially African women
you're black you're a woman you and then
you're dreaming no you know black woman
African no no no you can't you don't
have a right to it but I know that's not
true and that's the part of Storytelling
I know that before the young women of
today were born they were women from
their lineage who did not need
permission to become and my job was to
write the stories to my goddaughters but
along the line I thought hey why not
gift this book to girls around the world
especially African girls around the
world to know that they're women who eat
Fufu like them who ate chakalaka you
know and yamatooma like them you know
who have become great to Broken
boundaries and crushed ceilings and so
before the world tells my goddaughters
your daughter many young girls who they
can be when they see these stories they
know that the world is their oyster and
this is important because there's so
many research that shows for example
that Africa loses 95 billion dollars
annually because of gender equality
inequality wow as we said that shows
that you know GDP Grows by 0.3.37
percent when you know a girl child goes
to school you know there's many research
that shows that businesses with female
Executives you know tend to be more
profitable their research on cancer
research that also show that you know
male uh uh our Founders get access to
funds quicker than female Founders you
know but there's proof that shows that
female Founders you'll do very well in
business you know so it's all of that
you know I just want to see a better
world and so my passion began from
trying to you know create a spotlight
and put young people on and then from
there it expanded to gender you know to
women because if we have a fairer world
you know I think resources will go
around I think we'll have a better place
to live absolutely and fantastic Mission
and that I want to end with you know how
can we solve this how can we make sure
more women thrive on this continent and
what advice do you have for young women
who are trying to do not be afraid
um I think fear is a killer for anybody
do not be afraid if you dream run with
it if your spy you know to do something
go for it you will get no rejection does
not define your life it's just one
moment that prepares you to go and work
harder for the next so be Fearless you
know women there's research sure that
men apply for jobs that they are 60
qualified for women wait until they are
90 percent
you know so go for that job go in afraid
when they say do it afraid that's what
it means go in and do it you know and
Bank on ideas you know more women should
put their money on other women because
men put their money on men for you to
change the game more women have to put
their money on other women more women
have to fund other women in politics do
not let women go and start begging men
to fund their political careers they
don't want you in the room why should
they give you the money so more women
have to also take the risk women are
great money managers women are great at
spreading money and making sure that the
community is fine and that's a great
value we just need to just you know I'm
a bit more in terms of being able to
support you know women in other ways you
know and I think generally everyone
needs to bank on ideas from Africa IP is
the biggest thing now from the continent
uh music movies you know uh content
creation our fashion and that is why
this last year I launched aw Network
which is a media and Tech investment
firm where we Bank on ideas you have a
good film you have a good script you
have a tech business you're a content
creator sending your application follow
awnetwork.com Instagram
um or find me at Ebola Lagos you know
we're looking for ideas ideas on the
continent to put money in because people
do not give money to Media you know but
if people can give money to Tech you
know there's a market now I mean burner
boy is performing around the world you
know licensing
soundtrack there's so many opportunities
you know there's advertising money to be
made and so this is a sector that you
need to pay attention to absolutely well
thank you so much for being here and for
your amazing insights and congrats on
the book thank you thanks very much